[Music]
we come from different backgrounds
[Music]
from different countries
we have different interests
and different points of view
we aren't all developers
but it takes all of us every one of us
to make these games
the job you take very seriously
we try and break things
and fix things that are broken we keep
the teams happy and fed we keep our fans
happy and on the edge of their seats we
keep the books balanced
discover new talent and interact with
our community most of all we work
together as old friends
and you
what unites us is our passion for games
games as diverse as the people who make
them and play them
we're not just living the dream we're
creating it
we are all
[Music]
Bethesda Softworks how may I direct your
call mm-hmm you can start the show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and now please welcome the fez disclosed
senior vice president Pete Hines
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
thank you guys very much you sound good
I love you too
you look good you guys ready to go as
Paula said my name is Pete Hines and I'm
delighted to be back onstage for
Bethesda's fourth annual III showcase
now we've got all kinds of surprises in
store for you tonight so whether you're
here with us in the audience or you're
one of the millions who are watching
around the world settle in get ready for
the very best in gaming our theme this
year is create and it's a theme embraced
by our 10 studio spread around the globe
the incredibly talented folks who make
the Bethesda games that you'll soon be
playing but as you saw in our intro
video it's not just developers everyone
at Bethesda is a part of the team that
brings our games to life and that
extends to all of you because we create
the world's but you create your own
adventures stories and experiences and
it's your passion for games that drives
us every day to strive for excellence
the past year has been an exciting one
for Bethesda as we release some of the
best games of 2017 games like prey
dishonored death of the outsider the
evil within - Wolfenstein - we even
released exciting updates for the Elder
Scrolls online we brought we brought
full open-world VR with fallout 4 and
Skyrim + Doom VFR and we even released
our first two games for the Nintendo
swish so we were thrilled when
metacritic named us the top publisher in
the industry with the highest overall
across all of our gates but tonight is
about the future we're here to show you
where we're headed and the games that
we're creating that you'll soon be
playing the worlds that you'll be
inhabiting in the next year and beyond
so we're starting with a game that we
announced a few weeks ago through our
friends at Walmart Canada perhaps best
known for their low prices and ability
to keep a secret so let's get things
started with a look at rage 2
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]
my name's Andrew W K and we came to
partay
are you writing a rage
way
you you running away
[Music]
are you ready to read
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this is your tattoo bad
[Music]
with
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
let's give it up again through Andrew W
K the perfect song for Rage - hi
everyone my name is Tim Willits and I am
the studio director at ed software and
I'm Magnus niet Forster game director at
Avner studios and we're here to say that
rage is back now we had a ton of crazy
ideas when we started planning rage -
and we needed the right studio to bring
our vision to life
now we've admired the open world chaos
in all of Avalanche Studios games and as
we're about to show you they delivered
big-time
well thank you Tim yeah well speaking
for everyone that Avalanche Studios this
is a real a drink to come true for us
the world of Rage 2 is perfect for our
style of gameplay but even more exciting
than that has been to work with these
guys that he'd software these guys
invented the first-person shooter
[Applause]
and they still make the best shooters
out there so it's been a really great
collaboration to bring you the most
insane open-world shooter you have ever
played
so rage two transports players into a
dystopian future devoid of society law
and order now you play as Walker the
last Ranger of the wasteland now you
know I can talk all night about our guns
the powers you'll use the vehicle combat
and of course you know the crazy
open-world but I know that you are here
to see the game well not only do we have
rage two playable at our booth at e3 but
we've got for you an extended look at
the world and gameplay of Rage 2 let's
check it out
right now on a collision course with
earth
extinction event 80% of the Earth's
population dead God turned his back on
humanity long ago it wasn't a war was it
global warming it was a [ __ ] asteroid
I was born in this [ __ ] parents
murdered an orphan of this wasteland an
army of mutants killed everyone I ever
loved
all that's left is hate
fear and the need for survival
see part of growing up was watching
everything get taken from I stood by did
nothing and now I'm the last Ranger of
this wasteland and there's only one
thing left to do
hello III and welcome to the world of
Rage 2 in a moment
we'll dive headfirst into the Eaton
spaceport mission where Walker our main
protagonist is out to find a rare
artifact that will aid him in his quest
to take down the authority
[Music]
approaching the Eden Space Center yes I
forgot to say it might be overrun by
bandits
the goal is going to be precise you must
likely slay them first before calling
down the EcoPOD from orbit and securing
the gun take it nano try to Darien
doctor made the Space Center keep your
wits about your Walker the goons what
may look whimsical laughable even but
believe me behind their playful
appearance
it sings buckets bucketz diggings of
food it mounts on the wall its motion
sensor activated is the ruckus the
crusher talking at a key and it can be
yours while define rage
occasional to the EcoPOD Mission Control
the third floor
our second are no longer present threat
has been nullified mr. president welcome
excellent
now look for the central computer you
will initiate a recall procedure for
info 15 still in orbit we call sequence
approved beginning echo file record
EcoPOD made no and so does the authority
sorry
get the untainted nano-droids and get
out also for you there is an extra bone
something that will make you a veritable
so far here of elevator still running so
far so good
looks like Ranger Walker is gonna get a
bit of a boost today
[Music]
I said
Oh
oh yeah
[Applause]
from Bethesda Softworks
Christian vanHoose polical and everybody
I'm Christian vanHoose the community
manager for the elder scrolls legends
for the for the past year we have taken
what I think is the best digital card
game and made it even better new cards
new modes new ways to play and much more
but we wanted to push ourselves even
further so tonight I'm thrilled to
announce that we will soon be
relaunching the Elder Scrolls legends
with brand new totally overhauled
visuals I'm also very excited to let you
all know that legends will be available
later this year on Nintendo switch Xbox
one and PlayStation 4
[Applause]
but there's no reason to wait to play
the game that Apple awarded best of the
year in 2017
download the oldest girls legends for
free and join me tonight on PC mobile or
tablet in any progress you make in the
game it will be carried over to the
console versions through your Bethesda
net account and now let's take a look at
the future of Legends and see why this
isn't just my favorite card game but
will soon be yours as well it starts
small one game is all it takes but
legends never stay simple never stay
small this is action this is story this
is competition this is easy to pick up
this is hard to put down
this is a five minute train ride
this is a five-hour marathon
this is for anyway you play this is for
anywhere you play this is for strategy
fans this is for those who want magic at
their fingertips this is for those who
want dragons at their command
this is a game where legends are born
this is for you
[Applause]
from a ZeniMax online studios Matt fyra
[Applause]
thank you thanks everyone
I'm Matt fire on the game director on
the / scrolls online thank you
before I get started tonight I just want
to do a shout out it was really great we
started the showcase tonight with the
video highlighting the really talented
people that work behind the scenes to
make all of these great games possible
[Applause]
so standing here on stage I'm
representing a whole lot of amazing
people at ZeniMax online studios that I
go to work with every day it's a great
honor and privilege so I go to work with
them every day but at night I go home
log into Elder Scrolls online and I get
to play games with you guys the best
gaming community and online gaming
we are such big fans of what we do we
play the games just as you know we make
them and and we play them just as much
as you guys do it's what we do you know
so you might not know it but we're right
there alongside I'm playing there with
you I'm running dungeons I'm exploring
Tamriel questing crafting decorating my
house pvping stabbing yeah that was me
and I'm really humbled to say that the
older scrolls online community just
keeps getting bigger or over 11 million
players now and over a million of those
came in just the last year alone so last
year was really great for us in a whole
lot of ways we renamed MMO of the year
for the third straight year we released
morrowind a lot of great dlc and just
last week we released somerset the
latest chapter in the Elder Scrolls
online
[Applause]
it it's been it's been you know received
with great critical acclaim everyone
loves it you get to travel to the island
home of the High Elves for the first
time in 20 years it's great for new
players if in the off chance you aren't
playing Elder Scrolls online this is a
great chance to jump in and play and of
course all you veteran ESO fans are
already there but we're not done there
we make we make DLC every quarter for
friend chapters you know content comes
out so regularly for Elder Scrolls
online we're already working on our
great plans for next year but before
that the next DLC coming out is a
dungeon DLC named wolf hunter based on
werewolves and later this year we have a
story DLC named Merc mire
we're going back to Black Marsh so you
guys have all been asking for a deeper
dive into Argonian lore and culture
you're gonna see it later this year so
there's one theme that runs through all
of the Elder Scrolls Online's content
and that is great storytelling from the
launch game through all the DLC and
chapters it's really really what what
holds the game together but it's not
just the stories that we as developers
create for you guys to experience it's
also the stories that you create
together when you play this great
virtual world so I'm gonna leave you
tonight with video highlighting just
some of the amazing stories and
memorable characters that you'll meet on
your ESO journey thanks everyone see you
in Tamriel
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and thank you thanks so much
a Marty Stratton executive producer of
doom eternal Hugo Martin creative
director on doom eternal in 2016 we
launched our reboot of doom and have
been blown away by your support and
excitement for the game thank you
in fact it's a combination of your
passion and our team's love of making
doom that has motivated us to deliver
even more so we're back to announce doom
eternal an awesome awesome new sequel to
do for the past two years it's been so
inspiring to hear you guys talk about
what you'd like to see next and I gotta
tell you we're right there with you like
you want the doom Slayer to feel even
more powerful well we got it you want
even more badass demons well there are
twice as many in this game you want to
see hell on earth well we we just teased
it
but what we're most excited about is to
show you some of the things that you
might not be expecting
that's right including a ton of features
that we'll have to save for later
because our team will be debuting doom
eternal at QuakeCon this August we'd
love for you to join us live in Dallas
or of course you can tune in online to
catch all the fun but until then we want
to thank everyone who continues to play
doom thanks everyone thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
how's everybody feel tonight pretty high
just like a little hyper like crazy hype
right now right let's go Thanks hi I'm
Joshua Boyle community manager for Quake
champions thank you very much ever since
the first quake title was released in
1996 our games have been shaped by you
the players that proud tradition
continues with quake champions which has
evolved with community in mind and will
always be the fastest and most fun
multiplayer shooter period and that's
not the only tradition that quakes
continuing these days we're hearing a
lot of talk about eSports but quake has
been there from the very beginning in
fact we've started hosting competitions
at QuakeCon over 20 years ago
here for QuakeCon and this year we'll
expand on our legacy as the original
eSport with everything from intense
grassroots competitions to major
tournaments at QuakeCon End Dreamhack
winter
we've been doing this for a long time
and we're continuing to build with more
competitions for more players than ever
before
but I got to tell you guys we can't stop
won't stop until we've delivered a game
that's fun for everyone whether you're a
quake dad or a brand-new baby to the
arena that's why we just added a bunch
of new features to make it even easier
for you and your friends to jump in and
get good together
we're still in early access but tonight
we want to welcome all of you into the
arena for this week only we're opening
up quake champions to everyone through a
trial of our free-to-play version before
it even launches plus if you get in and
download this week you can stay keep
playing quake champions for free even
after the trial closes so head to quake
calm and start playing with me and all
of my quake family tonight
[Music]
don't miss your chance to join one of
the most passionate and welcoming
communities in gaming now for a taste of
what you'll be playing tonight after our
showcase is over check out our new
trailer for quake champions
[Applause]
tasty we'll find out out
the bigger the guns pretty good
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Aloise three from all of us at Arkane
studios here in Austin Texas it's been
one year since we launched pray and we
want to send a big thanks to our
incredible fanbase for your support
we've been so inspired by your passion
and enthusiasm and as a way of showing
our appreciation we're rolling out a
huge free update for prey tonight the
next time you fire up pray you're gonna
see three new modes story mode new game+
which was a big fan request and survival
mode which should be an interesting
challenge for our most hardcore fans but
that's just the beginning we are really
excited to tell everyone that we've also
been working on a new pray DLC an
infinitely replayable experience called
the moon crash it's a new twist on pray
where the enemies hazards and loot are
all different each time you play we're
so excited we can't wait to see what
the moon is a harsh mistress
the longer you're here the harder things
are going to get for you let's get to
work
let's get to work
to work
Oh electrical damage detective
two levels detective
[Music]
[Music]
get to work
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right before we begin yes mom I'm
still alive no I'm not a mimic hang on
there I just want to make sure nobody
tries to smack you because I saw Pete
Hines with a wrench backstage a second
ago Thank You Ricardo that's basic you
so like all arcade games prey is about
playing your own way and moon crash is
no exception so you just saw a lot of
cool stuff that's available tonight but
we're not done yet we have one more
surprise coming later this summer called
- hunter - hunter is a lethal game of
hide-and-seek where one player goes
head-to-head against five other players
who get to be mimics and just like in
prey the mimic players can disguise
themselves as everyday objects so you
know things like a chair a coffee mug a
space banana whatever works but
definitely not a co-worker right Susan
absolutely not
probably not
[Laughter]
[Applause]
- hunter is a tense multiplayer mode
that requires teamwork and improvisation
and a very high tolerance for jump
scares before we go I just want to say
thanks on behalf of the whole team at
Arkane studios to all of our fans around
the world who have played pray and love
it
we made this game for you and we are
constantly inspired by your creativity
and enthusiasm thank you so much
everyone
[Applause]
please welcome yen's matys and your
gustafson hello friends i'm yun smartest
creative director at machine games LOL
co-star song executive producer at
machine games last year millions of you
took to the streets and sparked a
revolution in Wolfenstein - the new
Colossus as BJ blaskowitz you rallied
the American resistance and you beat the
living [ __ ] out of those Nazis
[Applause]
thank you for embracing our game we were
honored to win best action game at the
Game Awards last December and we are
excited to bring Wolfenstein - to
Nintendo switch on you in 29th so you
can fight the notice on the go and the
Wolfenstein revolution continues with
our next project which leaps ahead in
time to tell the tale of BJ's twin
daughters set in the 1980s in Paris
Wolfenstein Youngblood pushes the story
forward
[Applause]
[Music]
and because this game features BJ's twin
daughters wolfish and young God will be
a co-op experience so while you can play
it solo you can also join with a friend
to save the world together the
resistance is counting on you all right
Holly boss let's check it out
[Applause]
[Music]
lesson children
I've been fighting all my life for this
world
arrest
[Music]
they're gonna send everything they have
at you to survive you have to embrace
the suffering
to stand up and carry it
it's not about the pain you can do
it's about how much you can take
it's do-or-die sis just like Papa taught
us
[Music]
[Applause]
hi epithets that we're proud of our
history of innovation and that includes
breakthrough VR technology that we
revealed at e3 2012
since then we've delivered some of the
very best VR experiences in gaming from
doom to fallout 4 to Skyrim and we're
not done two of the franchises that we
just heard about are gonna also offer VR
experiences
so when praise - hunter is released
later this summer you'll be able to
experience the competitive mood mode
that Susan and Ricardo were just talking
about in virtual reality and it will
also include a single-player experience
that puts you in the boots of Transtar
employees working to solve puzzles
aboard the Talos one space station I'm
also excited to announce a new
Wolfenstein VR game it's called
Wolfenstein cyber pilot in which you
play a hacker who can take over Nazi
robots and turn these war machines
against their masters in our ever ending
quest to bring the message of [ __ ] Nazis
to every platform possible
[Applause]
both the prey and Wolfenstein VR
experiences are playable this week at
our booth at e3 so please stop by and
give them a try now we are really
excited about everything that we've
shown here tonight but I know there are
a lot of you who are really here or
really wondering about fallout 76 and
I'm pleased to tell you that your wait
is finally over ladies and gentlemen
here's a recipient of numerous Lifetime
Achievement and Hall of Fame awards he's
the game director at a studio that has
won a bevy of accolades and awards and
he's here tonight to tell us what he and
his team have been taking so damn long
to tell us all about will you please
welcome my very good friend mr. Todd
Howard
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we're all here
looking good oh it's great to be back at
e3 thank you thank you so much I could
not be more excited to be here I want to
thank all our fans who came out tonight
and the millions of you watching online
we can't thank you enough
this is actually my 25th year at
Bethesda and I have seen I have seen a
lot of cool things in that time I gotta
say tonight is definitely definitely one
of them I got to go to the very first
III right here in Los Angeles I know
they're so cute when they're little
they're full of energy and life and then
remember one little III ran away from
home went to Atlanta yes you lot of you
didn't come I liked Atlanta or East
Coast's and then III went through the
the Moody teen years and came back and
locked itself in its room never it was
in the convention center but just in the
meeting rooms they didn't invite anybody
and I can remember literally walking
between the halls and seeing nobody I
was like this is how a zombie movie
starts and now III has grown up it's in
its 20s it's more confident can handle
its alcohol better like all of you thank
you
[Applause]
so there's a good there's a good party
after this so pace yourselves
and I hope you're comfortable by the way
I'm gonna be here for a while
and III has become such an incredible
week of entertainment but we know that
most of you came here for one thing
thank you
[Applause]
I think it's to see where we're putting
Skyrim next well I think we have the
best one yet
the elderscrolls speak of the past and
the future
now Skyrim looks to the future to its
ultimate version
Alexa play Skyrim your level 57 and see
a tall snowy mountain climate now Skyrim
and life become one a mud crabs cuddles
tortoise or doll I didn't catch that
I didn't catch all the way to so
Vanguard what happened
FUS ro dah that's the command for
knocking things over is there a command
for picking [ __ ] up every it's that
level yet I'm sworn to carry your
burdens oh the dragon unleashes fire
breath on you okay you have 7% health
left over [ __ ] I drink a health potion
you are out of health potions oh how
many wheels of cheese do I have left
473 can i eat all the cheese i eat all
of the seas
hey hon um remember what the doctor said
about dairy yes right yes of course
you're the greatest thank you so much I
ate all of introducing Skyrim very
special edition also coming soon to etch
a sketch Motorola pagers and your
Samsung smart refrigerator a sled goose
oh that's cool
[Applause]
had to had to do it had to do it okay
really
we both know why you're here and that's
to talk about the next fallout fallout
76 is a prequel to all the other games
and it's our biggest one yet it is four
times the size of fallout 4 set in the
hills of West Virginia you are one of
the first to emerge into an untamed and
very different wasteland
[Music]
[Music]
300 years after our great nation began
we gather together to honor the
completion of vault 76 this sprawling
underground shelter may have been
engineered by vault-tec but it was built
by you so that if the bombs do come our
way of life will endure
Almost Heaven
West Virginia
which mountain
I use old
[Music]
go
[Music]
he's country
[Music]
there
[Music]
[Music]
for when the fighting is stopped in the
fallout are settled
you must rebuild not just walls not just
buildings but hearts and minds and
ultimately America itself
[Music]
in volt 76 our future begins
[Applause]
vault 76 one of the very first vaults to
open was built to celebrate America's
tercentenary which is a awesome word by
the way
like that's your word of the night
tercentenary you are one of the very
special few selected to be an occupant
and spend 25 years underground waiting
for reclamation day the day the vault
opens good morning bout 76 this is the
overseer I hope you all enjoyed the
party last night
even those who may have overindulged and
overslept but it's time to get up and
get out there we've been locked away
long enough
today is reclamation day oh don't you
remember
time to leave football already it may be
time to leave but I'll never forget the
day you all entered vault 76 you come
from every walk of life every race color
and Creed but you all share one very
important trait you are this country's
best and brightest but more importantly
you'll always be my family
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we always start with the world and this
time it features all new rendering
lighting and landscape technology it
allows us to have sixteen times the
detail and even view distant weather
systems across the map
now most people don't know West Virginia
that well it is an incredible array of
natural wonders towns and government
secrets this is where the actual nuclear
secrets are and the quest the overseer
sends you on will take you through six
distinct regions each with their own
style risks and rewards there's plenty
of cool new fallout creatures and we
even use the folklore of West Virginia
to bring our Fallout versions to life
[Music]
we have always wanted to tell that story
of what it will be like for you and the
other characters who were first to leave
the vaults but there is one big
difference with this game it's that each
of those characters is a real person
[Applause]
because yes fallout 76 is entirely
online okay I know there's a lot you
have like a thousand questions right now
so I'm gonna go through them in order
now I'll had a couple of the big ones
first of course you can play this solo
alright you'll you'll be who you want
exploring a huge world doing quests
experiencing a story and leveling up we
love those things about our games too it
would not have it any other way but also
like many of you we have always wanted
to see what our style of game could be
with multiplayer so many of us talk
about experiences in our games but we've
never experienced them together
so about four years ago we hit upon an
idea that's perfect for Fallout open
world survival every person and
character is real and it was an idea
that we just couldn't shake we knew we
had to do it and do it in a really big
way now I know you may have played
survival modes and like some of our
previous games or some other online
games and we you know people wonder is
this hardcore survival I like to think
of it maybe it's more softcore survival
maybe that should be a new ESRB
descriptor death never means the loss of
progression or the loss of your
character your character isn't tied to
one server as a matter of fact you'll
never even see a server when you play
you'll be in a world with dozens not
hundreds and not thousands of other
players it's the apocalypse it's not an
amusement park okay
and you'll be able to join your friends
whenever you want and all of your
progression goes with you when we think
about games we think about worlds and
the choices that you can make the
stories that you create and tell
yourself by creating a wide open world
with very few rules we have a game more
than any game that we've ever done where
the choices are yours where you'll
decide what happens you'll decide the
heroes and you'll decide the villains
look this is a whole new world for all
of us here and fortunately our friends
at vaulteq have made a series of
informational videos for when all of us
have merged together
[Applause]
[Music]
as you venture out into this new
American frontier some of your fellow
survivors may not be neighborly
chin up there sport
not all vault 76 dwellers will be so
hostile find them and brave the new
world together whether you choose to
explore the wasteland alone or with
friends your days will be filled with
fun activities
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
like previous fallouts you can play this
game solo inquests but the easiest way
to survive in the wasteland is to team
up and build together and in this one
you can build wherever you want and you
can also then move that to wherever you
want after thermonuclear war man's
towering industrial marvels may no
longer stretch to the heavens what
separates man from Beast it is his
desire to build get started with your
hands the construction in assembling
mobile platform construct your home of
the future with your homes secure you
can now craft handmade ordnance at your
leisure to give your altercations that
personal touch it falls on you and the
ingenuity of your fellows to rebuild the
America we hold dear
but don't become too attached too
quickly monitor your environment for
anything out of the ordinary
the home of tomorrow may undergo certain
challenges
after a crisis work with your neighbors
to ensure success
there's no I in nuclear wasteland
document your adventures your memories
will shape the new American dream
what's that sound
there goes the neighborhood now we love
dynamic game systems so we thought why
don't we put multiple nuclear missile
sites on the map and then let all of you
do whatever you want with them
today's episode Atomics for peace when
you emerge from the comfort and safety
of your vault the world you know will
have changed take your friendly old
neighbor Johnny rather than coming over
to borrow a cup of sugar he may now be
coming over for murder the time has come
to seek out greater means of protection
nuclear armaments that's right
courtesy of your Uncle Sam these wonders
of the atomic age can be found right in
your own backyard but how does a fellow
like you acquire nuclear weapons you may
ask begin by inquiring with the locals
gently coax them into cooperation use a
little elbow grease if you have to
in the likely event you don't acquire a
full code on your own do not give up
search for others who might be harboring
a grudge you'll have that nuclear launch
code in no time with the power of the
atom at your fingertips be responsible
and consider your target carefully
attention launch sequence activated
will your bomb land on a rival camp of
degenerates a random stranger the local
wildlife whatever your target may be
take advantage of the resulting fallout
to gather rare and valuable resources
yet these rewards don't come without
risk
the fate of this new world is yours to
command with the power of the atom
[Music]
[Applause]
we know you've played a lot of our games
and a lot of online games but this one
really is unique we have built a
platform a hundred percent dedicated
servers that will support this game now
and for years to come
and look look we know this is new for
all of you it's new for us it's a little
bit scary and to that end we're gonna
need your help because yes we are going
to have a beta and it is sponsored by
our friends at vaulteq as well the
break-in early tests application
because evidently these online games are
hard they can have some nasty issues I I
read on the internet that our games have
had a few bugs I did I read it on the
internet so it's true and that sometimes
it doesn't just work anyway we know
together that we are going to build
something really special and we also
know that all of you love our special
editions and we have an awesome
collector's edition for you it starts
with a map of the world that glows in
the [ __ ] dark
yes right so cool
it comes with figures you can put on the
map and it also comes with a fallout
collectible that really I've always
wanted so we made them for everybody to
buy and here it is straighten up and fly
right straighten up and fly right
straighten up and fly right down don't
you blow your top ain't no use in diving
what's the use of diving cool down Papa
don't you blow your top
[Music]
[Applause]
yes all of this
the fallout 76 power armor edition so
you're probably wondering when is this
game coming out we're excited to say
that it's coming out this year
[Applause]
thanks again for all your support of
Fallout it's been ten years since
fallout 3 our very first one and it's
been an incredible journey with all of
you we do have another fallout
anniversary that we are celebrating here
at e3 it is the three year anniversary
of fallout shelter which we announced
and released right here at e3 and we
have some cool surprises for you
fallout shelter is coming to the
PlayStation 4 and because that guy said
it it's also coming to the Nintendo
switch you can play it with the joy cons
or touch controls and yes it's still
free
[Applause]
and excited to say these versions are
coming out tonight
[Applause]
again thank you so much for your support
of all that we do coming here tonight
when we see how many of you our games
have touched it's incredibly special
especially fallout shelter that game has
been played by over a hundred and twenty
million people that is more people than
every game that we have made combined
[Music]
incredibly it does kind of make you stop
and realize that our games can have new
lives on any type of device or system
and you know when we looked at the
iPhone eleven years ago we had a few
ideas from mobile games fallout shelter
was one of them and we did have another
one that was far far more ambitious and
we've been building it and it's in the
other franchise that you love from us it
is called the Elder Scrolls blades
[Applause]
like fallout shelter we wanted an
experience that we were not finding
anywhere else here it is
blades at its heart is a pure Elder
Scrolls game a massive first-person RPG
with console quality graphics but with a
uniquely mobile experience believe me
when I say you have to see this running
on an iPhone 10 this gigantic screen
does not do it justice you can tap to
move or use dual sticks
[Music]
combat is all-new and it follows your
specific movements and timings
[Music]
harkening back to the first Elder
Scrolls arena this game features both
handcrafted and procedurally generated
dungeons
and it's not just melee you have a range
of abilities and spells you can use
and of course you can create your own
character and be who you want to be
improving them levelling up picking new
abilities
[Music]
and the entire game can be played in
portrait mode
that one was incredibly important to us
that you could play up however you
wanted you never know when you'll need a
free hand
to hold your coffee what are you
degenerates
[Music]
and it's not just dungeons it's
incredible
outdoor areas yes running on a phone
it really looks and plays incredible
what place has several modes of play
first the abyss a robe like experience
where you can see how far you can go in
an endless dungeon in the arena where
you will do battle one-on-one against
other players and the main mode the town
this is the hub for your story and
quests you are a member of the blades
the Empire's top agents forced in exile
you return home to find your town
destroyed and need to rebuild it
yes blades also features a town building
mode you will decide what your town
looks like and be able to upgrade and
decorate all of the individual elements
in it as your town levels up you unlock
new NPC's quests and more you can even
visit your friends towns
[Music]
this
[Applause]
this is an Elder Scrolls game that you
can play however and wherever you want
and we are going to bring blades to
every device and system we can phones
PCs consoles also virtual reality on
mobile all the way up to high end VR on
PCs and what's really cool is all of
those connect to each other so one of my
dreams as we'll go back to that portrait
mode if you like to call meeting mode
because if you're in a meeting on you're
playing a game in portrait mode no one
knows you're playing a game and so with
blades you could be in a meeting playing
blades against someone at home in VR
blades is coming this fall for free
and you can pre-order it tonight on both
the Apple App Store and the Google Play
Store also this week go to play blades
comm and register for early access if
you're here at e3 blades is going to be
playable on our booth so please come by
and check it out you really need to see
it running on the phone we'd love to see
you please come by
[Applause]
I just want to thank you all again all
of our fans here everybody watching
online for all of your support over the
years
it is so exciting to show you all that
we have coming out this year and it is
an honor and a blessing to represent all
of the incredible people at Bethesda
Game Studios we have three offices now
in Maryland Montreal and Austin there's
a lot of them here tonight I want them
to hear your appreciation for their work
[Applause]
just the best team and group of people I
could ever hope for
I'm a amazing we also thought since
we're all here together tonight and it's
so special maybe we do something a
little different too and tell you what
we have coming beyond this year in the
future we have also been working on a
brand new next-generation single player
game but this one is in an all-new epic
franchise our first wholly original
franchise in 25 years
[Music]
[Applause]
we're excited to announce our next
adventure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
starfield is a game that we have spent
years thinking about and working on
something we feel uniquely positioned to
pull off and that we're incredibly
excited about but we're also building
toward the game after that and it's the
one you keep asking about
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay actually now I'm really done I just
want to thank you all for your time
tonight the time you've spent in our
worlds we'll see you out there
[Music]
can I get another round of applause
please
another round of applause please for
Todd Howard
[Applause]
we only get him up here like once every
three e threes but boy when he shows up
he brings the goods thanks also to all
of our studios and teams around the
world who are so dedicated to giving our
fans the very best games if you're a
gamer on any platform of any time we
think we've got something for you and I
hope you're as excited about what you've
seen tonight as we are whether it's a
new Fallout game a new Elder Scrolls
game from Bethesda Game Studios that you
can play on your phone for free rage to
doom eternal and so much more we're
really excited now remember if you want
to be one of the first to play Elder
Scrolls blades or join the fallout 76
beta you need to go to Bethesda net and
register it's easy and it's free for all
of you here with us tonight thank you so
much for joining the party is gonna
continue afterwards for everyone else
around the world thank you so much for
joining us everyone have a good night
and a grade III
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm just kidding I love you hi everyone
welcome back to GameSpot's coverage of
e3 2018 that show ended I don't even
know there's Elder Scrolls six star
filled things we knew were real but
Bethesda's admitting it now I don't know
if you weren't here for the pre-show I'm
Mike McCarty I'll be hosting for the
next half hour so as we wind down the
evening here and sunny San Francisco
here's Pete Brown hi
Lucy James and Jess MacDonald Bethesda
that was the longest press conference
ever that's what this [ __ ] was about 85
minutes okay I am I mean it started off
on definitely a slow note a cringy note
rage to stuff it took them like what 10
minutes to finally get to gameplay of
anything there is a lot of awkward